et tu arrives des nouveaux iPhone
s'envolent cette année on a passé la
barre des 1000 euros sur l'iPhone 14
1019 euros + 110 euros par rapport à la
génération précédente
1359 euros pour l'iPhone 14 pro plus 200
euros par rapport à la génération
précédente
1479 € pour l'iPhone 14 pro max dans la
configuration la plus basse plus 220 €
par rapport à la génération précédente
pour arriver à 2129 euros sur la plus
grosse configuration de l'iPhone 14 pro
max en intera l'Apple watch série 8
frôlent avec les 500 euros à 499 euros
plus 70 euros par rapport à la
génération précédente la Watchers
pro passe à 299 euros plus 20 euros par
rapport à la génération précédente une
augmentation du coût de la vie et une
inflation tout coûte plus cher là
forcément on voit aussi chez Apple je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dites le
moi dans les commentaires et puis pour
tout savoir de la cutech je vous invite
à venir vous abonner